لقطات كاميرا أمنية لما كان
سيصبح قريبًا أحلك أيام نيوزيلندا ،
يُظهر هذا الفيديو من 15 مارس أشخاصًا
يتجولون بشكل عرضي في الساعة 1:42
بعد الظهر تم تصويره من كاميرا في
فندق يقع على بعد حوالي 300 متر من
سلسلة مسجد النور وطلقات نارية
خرج من ما يبدو أنه نوعين مختلفين
من الأسلحة النارية ، وعلى الرغم من أن هذه
هي بداية هجوم إرهابي مميت ، إلا أن
المارة ليس لديهم أي فكرة
عما يحدث في مكان قريب ، إلا
أنه بعد مرور أربع دقائق تقريبًا ،
أظهر المشاة علامات الإنذار  ثم
تظهر هذه السيارة ، حيث يطارد السائق
بوقه لجذب انتباه المشاة ،
ثم يطلق النار عبر النافذة الجانبية للركاب
على رجل على الرصيف ،
ويقول أصحاب الفندق إنهم شاركوا هذه
الكاميرا الأمنية مع
شرطة نيوزيلندا ولن يعلقوا
على  فيديو أثناء التحقيق الجاري ،
تصوّر الكاميرا هذا
الامتداد من الرصيف ،
وتكشف اللقطات عن تفاصيل مهمة حول
الهجوم الإرهابي الأكثر دموية.
تاريخ نيوزيلندا الحديث أولاً في غضون
لحظات من أول طلقة نارية مسجلة ،
يمكنك سماع صفارات الإنذار
تدعم تصريحات الشرطة التي
كانت تندفع إلى مكان الحادث في غضون دقائق
من أول مكالمة طوارئ ، ولكن ثانيًا
، كان المسلح يائسًا جدًا في القتل لدرجة
أنه توقف هنا و  أطلق الرصاص
من نافذة سيارته على الضحية
بينما كان في طريقه من المسجد الأول
على الطريق إلى مسجد آخر ولا
تزال الأرض هنا مليئة
بالزجاج من سيارته.
الهجوم على
مسجد النور ومن ثم
مسجد لينوود ، نعتقد اعتقادًا راسخًا أننا
أوقفناه في طريقه إلى
هجوم آخر ، لذلك تم إنقاذ الأرواح ،
تكشف الشرطة الآن
تفاصيل إضافية حول خطة المشتبه بهم
لن أخوض في هذه التفاصيل.  أنت
تعلم أنني لا أرغب في إيذاء الآخرين
بحيث يشكل ذلك جزءًا من القضية
ولكننا نعتقد تمامًا أننا نعرف إلى أين
كان ذاهبًا وتدخلنا بشأنه
الطريقة التي تظهر بها لقطات الكاميرا الأمنية
المشتبه به وهو يتسابق بعيدًا عن طريق
إطلاق النار بعد حوالي 15 دقيقة ،
اعتقلت الشرطة المشتبه به
استمر هيجانه أقل من نصف ساعة
برد سريع من الشرطة ، لكن
لم يكن ذلك كافياً لمنع هذا
القاتل المصمم من  ادعي 50
حياة بريئة على الأقل أنا